you
being nominated fell like honor
unbelievable it was exciting
legal hi I guess I just flipped out over
it it's kind of like when a pinata
breaks open and everything comes
spilling out
people are like I feel I'm so humbled by
these moments like no I feel like the
greatest completely shocker
really proud you don't get moments like
that every day
that was a moment in time for sure the
Academy Award do you think you know
that's not how it's always been
in 1929 there were no nominations and
the winners were announced in advance so
today we're going to change things up
again and we're going to invite pass
Oscar nominees and winners to help
welcome this new class and to actually
walk them through the next 33 days for
that year I was part of that small
selected group of the brightest stars
and I was able to bring my mother to the
Oscars who always wanted to be an
actress and she got to sit right next to
me and be so proud of me
walking on that stage the nominees for
supporting actor are Maher Sheela Ali in
moonlight Jeff Bridges in hell or high
water
Lucas hedges in Manchester by the sea
Dev Patel in Lyon and Michael Shannon in
nocturnal animals the nominees for
cinematography are
a rival la-la-land lion
moonlight and silence a song rang and my
lawyer was on the phone my love doesn't
wrong he said you were nominated for an
Oscar but I was by myself in this hotel
I didn't have anybody near me any family
and before I had the chance to call my
mom the my door rang and the waitress
came in and I disperses Jasmine
nominated for an Oscar since you put the
tray down she said gives a hug
documentary feature fire at sea I am NOT
your Negro life animated oj made in
america and 13th best documentary Short
subject extremis 4.1 miles
Jose violin what Johnny my homeland and
the white helmets we are fortunate and
of course you should have fun with all
of this but a day after the very next
day after the Oscars the focus should be
back to making film good cure the
nominees for foreign language film are
land of mine from Denmark
a man called Eva from Sweden
the salesman from Iran Tana from
Australia Toni aired month from Germany
the no need for live-action shows Anna
means Antalya the farm is a KJV silent
night thing and timecode when I heard my
name I think I just about passed out and
then when I heard Lenny Abrahamson names
director of room that's when I really
lost
mind there's just the best moment of my
life
the nominees for lead actor are Casey
Affleck in Manchester by the sea Andrew
Garfield in hacksaw Ridge Ryan Gosling
in la-la-land Viggo Mortensen in Captain
Fantastic and Denzel Washington in
fences the nominees for sound editing
are a rival Deepwater Horizon hacksaw
ridge la-la land and sully the nominees
for sound mixing are a rival hacksaw
Ridge la-la-land
rode one a Star Wars story and 13 hours
the secret soldiers of Benghazi very
early in the morning and the first thing
I did was a wake up my wife I think
immediately goes someone that is going
to take you down a few notches that's
why I woke up my wife the nominees for
production design our arrival fantastic
beasts and where to find them
Hail Caesar lala land and passengers the
nominees for visual effects are
deepwater horizon
Doctor Strange the Jungle Book
Kubo and the 2 string and rogue one a
Star Wars story
[Music]
we were making the Big Chill and I heard
it and I sa tanning when I stop smack
out of out of the blue I had no clue I
had no expectation costume design allied
fantastic beasts and where to find them
Florence Foster Jenkins Jackie and lala
land
makeup and hairstyling a man called Eva
Star Trek beyond and Suicide Squad a
score of music in a film that is like to
me the most impactful and powerful music
let's not forget about jobs with it does
Donna Turner donor that's like that type
of power that it exudes to drive you
every emotion through the film and you
don't even notice what's driving your
emotion that is powerful the nominees
for Original Score are Jackie Mika levy
la-la-land justin her with lions
Dustin O'Halloran and Hauschka moonlight
nicolas brittle and passengers thomas
newman the nominees for original film
are audition the fools who dream from
lala land can't stop the feeling from
trolls city of stars from lala land the
empty chair from jim the james foley
story how far I'll go from Moana
[Music]
my big piece of advice when you're
nominated is not to pop the champagne
right away because that's going to
continue for a long time in this case
maybe 33 days and you got a big job
ahead of you you might have to give a
speech in front of millions and millions
of people and you don't wanna screw it
up the nominees for Original Screenplay
are hell or high water
Taylor Sheridan la-la-land Damien
Chazelle the lobster
Jurgis Londo Mos Espa most Filippo
manchester by the sea Kenneth Lonergan
and 20th century women Mike Mills
and the nominees for adapted screenplay
our arrival
Eric Heiser ur fences August Wilson
hidden figures Allison Schroeder and
Theodore Melfi lion Luke Davies and
moonlight Barry Jenkins and Tarell Alvin
McCraney so the first time that I really
truly ever experienced the Academy in
the Oscars was when I was there
nominated for an Oscar and I hadn't
stopped watching you since the nominees
for Animated Feature are Kubo and the
two strings
Milana my life is a zucchini the red
turtle and Zootopia the nominees were
animated short are blind Visha borrowed
time pear cider and cigarettes pearl and
Piper
I got to meet Lee Daniels the director
and he just gave me the role after about
30 to 45 minutes of talking and so I
don't know how other people get
nominated for Oscars but for me was
hella Evie here are some more of this
year's nomination actress in a
supporting role
Viola Davis in fences Naomi Harris in
moonlight Nicole Kidman in Lion Octavia
Spencer in hidden figures and Michelle
Williams in Manchester by the sea film
editing arrival hacksaw Ridge hell or
high water la-la land and moonlight my
phone rang it was my father and we both
just started crying and neither of us
could finish the sentence it was one of
the greatest moments of my life and
there's two years later that we actually
got nominated together for out in the
air and the nominees for lead actress
are Isabel repair in L ruth negga in
loving natalie portman in Jackie Emma
Stone in la-la land and Meryl Streep in
Florence Foster Jenkins
directing arrival denis villeneuve
hacksaw ridge mel gibson la-la-land
Damien Chazelle Manchester by the sea
Kenneth Lonergan and moonlight Barry
Jenkins - our global community and
filmmakers and fans and to everyone who
is inspired by movies and loves them as
much as we do thank you so much for
joining us this morning I'm thrilled to
be here with Cheryl to welcome the
nominees for the 89th economy room and
I'm specially honored to help announce
this year's nominees for Best Picture
arrival fences hacksaw Ridge hell or
high water hidden figures lala land
flyin manchester by the sea moonlight
congratulations to all the extraordinary
artists and filmmakers nominated today
it's going to be a great show huge
congratulations congratulations
congratulation the idea of you being an
Oscar nominee is actually now part of
your name - the day you die embrace this
moment because it's being nominated
alone makes you a winner make a speech
anyway because there's nothing more
boring than an unprepared actor I want
to congratulate all the nominees and I
advise them to wear comfortable shoes to
the ceremony get sleep when you can
sneak into the Oscars with a flask and
have a good time